hey Vsauce Michael here and today we are
going to talk about time specifically
how much time we have what's feet oldest
a person can ever be well the world
record for the world's longest living
person belongs to Gen Cal MA a French
woman who lived to be 122 right now at
this very moment there are only 37
people alive who were born in the 1800s
those 37 people have lived in three
different centuries but as medical
knowledge expands and our understanding
of biology improves people are living
longer and longer in fact scientists
believe that based on statistics the
first person who will ever live to be
150 has already been born it could be
one of you but according to the map it's
probably someone who was born last year
here's the thing as humans get older the
likelihood of them dying increases but
there are some types of animals that
have what is called negligible
senescence also known as biological
immortality and these types of animals
have never been observed to actually age
animals like the Hydra can only die
because of accidents disease or
predators the world's oldest living
individual tree has clocked in at more
than 4,600 years old it's called the
Methuselah tree and it exists somewhere
in this forest
government officials won't actually
release its exact location to protect it
from vandalism but it's out there the
lifespan of an organism can be even
longer than that if you include clonal
colonies for instance these quaking
pines all look like individual trees but
they're actually all clones of one
genetic code they all share a root
system and the root system continues to
make more trees meaning that these trees
are all part of the same organism and
experts have calculated based on the
root system that this one male quaking
pine
has been around for at least 80,000
years but let's get back to humans and
rather than talking about how time is
let's talk about how time feels intense
moments of your life are remembered as
lasting much longer than times that were
relatively dull psychologists say that
the reason for this is that our brains
take deeper and richer memories of
events that are novel or events that are
intense than ones that aren't when your
experiences are intense and novel you're
not remembering more things about it but
you are making more copies rather than
just making normal memories during
stress the amygdala gets involved and
also remembers things and many people
believe that is why intense moments are
remembered as lasting longer this
phenomenon becomes quite mind-blowing on
a macro scale think of it this way when
you are a one-year-old baby one year
represents 100 percent of your life but
when you turn 2 years old that second
year was only half your life and the
next year you live through is only a
third of your life and by the time you
turn 80 one year only represents an 80th
of your life those percentages are
important because they may explain why
your childhood feels like it took so
long but as you get older the years seem
to fly by you have more novel
experiences when you're young you first
learn a language you first see your
mother you first learn to walk you have
your first kiss these are all deeply and
richly remembered by your brain and so
later on it feels as if they took longer
to happen now here's what's really
mind-blowing let's look at a graphical
representation of the percentage of your
life that each successive year is the
first year is 100% the second year is
only 1/2 the third gear is a third and
so on we'll go all the way out to 80 now
using this representation under this
model when you turn 80 years old and
look back at your life the point that
feels like the middle isn't near 40s
it's your early 20s the good news here
is that the more novel things you do and
thing
you see in places you visit and people
you meet the slower time feels and the
more rich it feels so go out there and
do something cool do something weird do
something new subscribe to Vsauce if you
haven't already and as always thanks for
watching